foreign
I'd really appreciate if if one of you
would feel comfortable to to actually
Define what danger theory is and what
adaption is for our audience I don't
know who who feels up for that me or
Annie I know um I can I can give it a go
and then Peter can support me um he's
the professor she's the immunologist
well
um so danger theories this theory that
was um proposed by um pulley matsinger
in 1994 which was a time when you know
Immunology was going undergoing some
sort of change we had this model of the
self as non-self that was proposed in
the late 50s and then that sort of
evolved when people said well you know
we need more signaling this is not quite
a complete model and then um you know
other another immunologist Charles Jen
we came up with um the self versus
infectious non-self
to sort of give a bit more resolution to
what he what we meant by non-self and
then um in I think that was in 89 and
then in 94 pulley
um or Professor matzinger had come up
with you know it's not just self versus
non-self-certainty there must be
something more and she said you know it
is the dangerous signaling or danger
Theory and basically what she said is
that not just your immune cells but
every single cell in your body has got
the possibility to send out this danger
signal so in Immunology we've got two
main signals that would sort of
kick-stat an immune response and the
first is holding out that poster and
saying hey there's something wrong here
and your immune system your immune cells
sort of traffic there and then the
second would be the thing holding out
that poster and your immune Cell saying
yeah this is definitely
non-self and then there's another
signaling Cascade that happens and she
said no you need a third signal and that
third signal is that you need danger
molecules
coming in to sort of
push that along
and um while you know even for Professor
Matt singer she's you know it's she
hasn't quite
um fleshed it out as you know we
understand the flesh Other Self as a
non-self model
um
there are still some loopholes with that
theory and then with adaptation
um it's basically challenging the idea
that your immune system is stagnanted it
says you know it has to be contextual
you know you have to put in the
environment you have to put in what is
going on and your immune system is able
to change in a reversible way to adapt
to whatever is going on
um yeah I agree with that and if you
think of it walking into a dark room
right you don't see anything from the
beginning and then after 30 seconds or
so your vision adapts and you start
seeing
Contours around you and so on
and what that basically illustrates is
that the immune system is a sensory
system just like your vision and it must
sense relative changes not absolute
changes
I hope that makes sense so
if you go from from one state to another
it's the change that's important it's
not the absolute amount
and and and because in order to do that
the system must constantly adapt just
like your vision like your hearing or
your senses
and and and so that fits with the idea
that adaptation on goes on all the time
however none of these things would
explain why in covid for example the
majority have a very mild infection and
then a few individuals have a massive
severe infection
and so these things are not there's
something more here there's a layer of
Regulation that we still don't fully
understand which causes this enormous
variability among people that's
interesting
yeah I'd um just like to emphasize and
and illustrate some of the these points
in infectious diseases
um that infectious diseases mostly
the damage that you get is caused by
your immune system mostly I I work on
mostly on two diseases tuberculosis and
meningitis and they're both really the
damages caused by the immune system I
know the immune system is the most
dangerous thing in this room
it could kill you in a minute if your
immune system is activated these
dangerous signals is to any and people
have been talking about they are so
strong that you can get allergic shock
that will kill you in minutes
there's nothing no microbe can do that
but your immune system can if it's
activated so your immune system has this
good and bad it causes damage it it will
clear diseases
it will cause
um it will
um kill microbes but in doing so it has
to kill cells and when these danger
signals get the high level it creates it
for example in tuberculosis one of the
diseases I work with it'll cause holes
in your lungs it will cause so much
damage that your lungs will fill up with
holes and they will fill up with fluid
and eventually you'll drown in your own
lungs because they've got so much fluid
in them and that's mostly caused by the
immune system
similarly meningitis another terrible
disease it's called caused by one of the
things actually also happens in covet a
cytokine storm as it's called where the
danger signals are so strong that they
cause your immune system to go into
hyper mode in which the kind of
information that you normally get if you
say cut your finger and you'll get some
information added on your finger will
actually happen in your entire body and
all your blood vessels will dilate to
allow fluid to flow out of your body and
you go into shock which means that your
blood pressure will drop down so low
that you're not able to perfuse your
your organs and again that can happen in
in meningitis in a matter of hours so
and that's caused really by the immune
system so or that that balance is a
delicate balance and
um it can be triggered in lots of
different directions and much of the
damage that microbes cause are actually
caused by our immune system but without
it we'll be dead
so it's a tricky one can I can I just
say that the only thing you know um the
immune system is a very powerful system
but I would use the word
potentially
um you know I would I would qualify what
you've said with potentially because
it's also very heavily regulated
it's very very heavily regulated so it
wouldn't um um you do need the cytokines
at the start of your immune response in
order to initiate the immune response
and to sort of pass it along to the next
cells that will do what they do but that
balance is kept very much under control
it does get dysregulated in certain
cases but um at the bulk majority of the
times it is kept under control
that's really interesting I mean it's
also reassuring to hear that we can't
just go nuclear at the drop of a hat
um so I mean just thinking back to the
question which was you know can can
these two new sort of theories
um or relatively new theories of this
danger Theory where you have these sort
of signals that indicate that you know
there's danger happening and the second
theory being this sort of adaption
theory of the immune system where you
know it can learn and be smart and adapt
and what literally adapt to its
environment so can these two sort of new
ways of understanding the immune system
actually help address disease was the
question but I feel like already in what
you what what the three of you have been
saying is it becomes very apparent that
disease is almost too broad a term right
that you've all discussed there's
microbes there's things from the outside
there's what happens when the body
suddenly starts to see other parts of
the body is different the effect of that
I mean just to be really basic here
what is disease
our disease I mean I'm a doctor right
the first thing you learn is that
disease is the app is anything that is
you know disruption of balance or
homeostasis or anything anything really
um and health is defined as the absence
of that disease
so you could you could philosophize you
know you have a long discussion around
that you know
um yeah but I think the the this idea
that danger Theory and adaptation will
explain
um we'll explain the immune system
better than self-known self I think is
clear but it doesn't explain it all
right
um there are there are you know think of
transplantation you transplant an organ
from one individual to another one
um that doesn't necessarily trigger
danger signals
um it doesn't necessarily lead to an
Adaptive change but it's rejected the
organ is rejected
um that's sort of the basis for the
self-non self-discrimination from the
beginning
however if you do the exact same
procedure very early in life that's
tolerated and in mice for example you
can do this and then you don't need to
suppress the immune system of the
accepting host
so adaptation the point of that is that
adaptation yes but it's very different
the system is very amenable during a
certain window of time and then for the
rest of the life it's more static
and so we have to also keep that in mind
that there are different phases just
like puberty is another developmental
phase where we have a unique biology and
Physiology and so on
that's interesting I mean what do you
think
um yeah I think it's uh it's very
interesting how your immune system
adapts to yourself and learns who you
are really and okay I'm not gonna I'm
not going to
um attack this tissue and that balance
is is critical to health and it keeps
you alive and microbes also learn to
manipulate it there's another bug called
the leprosy bacillus
and for reasons that we didn't really
understand at all when the leprosy silos
infects you it switches off your immune
system's attack to it you become
allergic as it's called to it the
leprosy bacillus so it's it's somehow
able to manipulate the immune system to
say to the immune system hey I'm I'm
okay I'm one of the boys I'm one of
yourselves don't hit me and lots of
microbes can do that
and I think what would be really good
and and scientists are working on this
if we could understand how microbes
manipulate our immune system we might be
able to better manipulate our immune
system in order to prevent a lot of the
disease as Peter's already said I think
that a lot of the pathogenesis of covert
for example it's actually the immune
system in disarray it's doing too much
we really need to understand that and
maybe dissecting how over millions of
years
the pathogens that we are dealing with
have we've dealt with them and we
managed to
um live comfortably with many of them
learning how that works will could help
us to kind of correct some of the
conditions that we still suffer from
I
mean
I think I said already right so I'm a
biologist as well I love this idea that
like the more we learn about the immune
system the more we'll be able to step in
and help regulate it to sort of better
better facilitate Health in in in those
circumstances basically so I I really
appreciate that that said I'm now going
to sort of push us a little bit more
into the Realms of philosophy so
strapping to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas